ليس القصف والاجتياح البري التركي وحده ما
يخشاه الاكراد في سوريا اذ ان هناك ما
يشغل بالهم اكثر وهو التقارب بين انقره
ونظام الاسد في سوريا وهو ما قد يعود سلبا
مستقبلا على اداره ذاتيه الكرديه شمال شرق
البلاد وهو ما تعارضه انقره بشده وتعتبر
وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه منظمه ارهابيه
مرتبطه بحزب العمال الكردستاني لكن كيف
تطورت العلاقات بين انقره والنظام السوري
التي شهدت مراحل دراماتيكيه كيف لا
واردوغان الذي كان يصف بشار الاسد بالمجرم
لا يستبعد اليوم اللقاء به لما يخدم الامن
القومي
ففي عام 2012 وما عندي لها الاحداث في
سوريا اغلقت تركيا سفاراتها في دمشق
احتجاجا على قمع نظام الاسد للمتظاهرين
السوريين وقرر اردوغان اتهامه للاسد
بالمجرم في ما وصف الاخير نظيره التركي
بدعم الارهاب وبعدها قدمت ان دعما كبيرا
للمعارضه السوريه وتحولت اسطنبول الى مقر
للائتلاف الوطني لقوى الثوره والمعارضه
السوريه قبل ان تبدا دعم الفصائل المعارضه
المسلحه وتوالت بعدها الوعود التركيه على
لسان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بمحاسبه بشار
الاسد على ممارسته بحق المتظاهرين
والمعتقلين السوريين وتوعد باسقاط الاسد
عن الحكم مهما كالف الامر لكنه اردوغان
اليوم الذي لا يستبعد عوده المياه الى
مجارها الى بل حتى اللقاء والمصالحه مع
نظام البشري الاسد بقوله انه لا خلاف
ابديه في السياسه وان اللقاء مع الاسد قد
يحصل بعد الانتخابات التركيه في عام 2013
سوريا
[موسيقى]
لازمته
خالص
[موسيقى]
الاصيل